she is elena starkov we can't believe
how dark the new shadow and bone series
could have been had they stuck to the
book
the darkest scene from the novel was
actually tamed down for the series
and the effect it has for our heroine
elena is major
how did the relationship between elena
and kerrigan change from the book to the
show
which characters were made just for the
series
what are you
while the series did make some changes
to what was written in the shadow and
bone novel
including the addition of the characters
from the six of crows book
one of the most surprising changes
definitely came to the end of the season
which was
much darker in the novel when we see
kiergan left behind at the end of season
1 and elena helping bring the skiff and
everyone who'd survived to safety
it makes sense and leaves us feeling
good but the book saw
many more people abandoned instead of
saved the novel had our heroine alina
starkov realizing she could fully
control her powers and fleeing the skiff
with mal
and her protective cone of light into
the shadowfold
yes this means that she left behind not
just kiragan
but everyone who betrayed her and
refused to help her fight
so why did the show make this change
showrunner eric heiser said that with
the inclusion of the characters who
weren't originally in the shadow and
bone book who wound up being on the
skiff in the end
the whole team felt that the connection
and the work the characters of the show
did together
demonstrated teamwork strong enough to
save them the bond was strong and real
so together they could be allies and
support each other
while this does make a major difference
for what we feel about elena
it still does stay in line with the
spirit of the novel and we still see
alina making tough decisions
even if they weren't as grim it wasn't
just that point that was edited though
kiragan's harshness was actually toned
down a bit as well
the book includes a very intense and
harsh speech and a confrontation with
alina
but this was made to be much gentler and
kinder in the show
some of the lines from the conversation
in the book are also instead used in
keurig's conversation with mal
since kiergen is such a complex and
difficult character
something we can definitely all agree on
the team behind the show
felt that whenever a moment of empathy
for kiragan could be added it should be
in order to make him a more accessible
character in the series
as despicable as he is the show
definitely did a great job at making him
a more empathetic character
perhaps even ben barnes who portrayed
him agreed that exploring the humanity
of kierrigan was important
and the actor said he would definitely
be up for continuing that journey into
season two
our fingers are crossed i just want to
talk to you
i've had enough of your lies
speaking of the changes to kiragan's
portrayal there were more
that's right remember that first kiss
alina gives kirigan
well in the books it was kiergen who
made the first move
catching alina off guard when he did it
when things did get a bit steamier
between the two in the novel
they get interrupted but when their
intimate moment comes in the show
kiergen stops and actually makes sure he
has alina's consent
this was added by the actor ben barnes
even while playing a pretty deplorable
character he wanted to make sure the
offer of consent was included with the
addition of the line
we are big fans of these changes and the
creators behind the show had good reason
for it as well
the writers directors and actors of the
show all felt that
since it was based on young adults
novels that there would be a lot of
younger audience members
so it was really important to take the
opportunity to include moments
displaying alina's agency and control
over her choices with her body
as a result the show has sent a really
powerful message about consensual
interactions and portraying a strong
woman with the agency to make the
choices based on what she
actually wants overall the show focuses
on the fantasy of the world
and only includes the more graphic and
risque scenes to serve the storytelling
making it way more about the characters
and the journeys that they go on
the appeal is the story passion and
fantasy
and the team absolutely nails this in
shadow and bone
that means a lot to me
now for the other differences and extras
included in the show that we didn't get
in the novels
of course having the six of crows
characters and zoya as part of the
battle against kiragan was a major
change
later in the trilogy we see zoya and
alina as allies but her inclusion this
early hints that zoya switched sides and
supported elena earlier than the novels
depicted
this pretty much set her up to take on a
major role in a second season which
still falls in line with the progression
of the novels so we're excited to see
where that journey goes
we know that kaz jesper and edge were in
the six of crows novel
but the storylines they have in shadow
and bone were created just for the show
giving us a kind of backstory for all of
them in preparation of what they could
face in the six of crows story
how about mal and elena well mal is a
kinder and more caring person in the
show
always looking out for alina and her
safety what we did miss was the kiss the
two shared in the book
we aren't really sure why it was cut we
did get some suggestive moments of
romance between them
maybe something will happen in season
two while alina's heritage isn't
specified in the book
it was announced before the role was
even cast that elena would be half shoe
giving the opportunity to amplify the
stakes for elena
some lines from the novel were even
adjusted a bit so we could see the
racism that elena
faced as someone who was half shoe in
this world what's a hugh girl doing here
by the way the conductor in general's
latin weren't in the books
they were both characters created just
for the show and they definitely add a
good amount of color and story to the
series
i don't know where it came from came
from everywhere
while the show did take some creative
liberties with shadow and bone and chose
not to go with as dark a story as the
books
it still hits the mark in every way we
definitely hope there's a second season
with a finale like that we need to see
what happens next for elena
how do you feel about the changes the
series made to the story
you